change why Seattle udonge Alive's change
organizations guy [ __ ] the organization
also might change the world
and it is my delight to bring up our
next speaker Maile lassika before the
GSB she worked in consulting as well as
at Caribou Coffee
after the GSB our for her summer
internship she is headed to Amazon Maile
welcome so I'm looking up at the upper
layer up level and I see column by
himself and I'm wondering if he's a
little bit lonely maybe but luckily a
Katrina in Rome we have joined him so
it's feeling good and I see an buyer in
the back and I'm thinking about
accounting and how I actually found out
I liked it when I thought I was going to
hate it and I see my house for next year
and my boyfriend and then a lot of faces
I don't know my name is Maile and I have
ADHD I also have allergies so apologies
if I sniffle during the presentation but
what I want to talk to you today about
is just a couple things one what's it
like to have ADHD - good news most
people with ADHD by the time you get to
be my age we know how to deal with it
and what those ways you deal with it are
and then the part that I think is going
to matter to each and every one of you
is how when you manage someone that has
ADHD how you can maximize that
relationship so first what's it like to
have ADHD well there's some good and
there's some bad and I'm gonna get the
bad out of the way first
so when you have ADHD social
relationships are actually kind of hard
because let's say I was trying to bond
with Jenna right now I'm supposed to
look her in the eye and ask her
questions and show interest but I'm
thinking about my leg shaking and I kind
of want to scan the room and I'm not
creating that one-on-one connection
that's so important to forming those
bonds and when you have ADHD you're
forgetful any of my friends can attest
to this but in terms of like school and
work it takes me if I don't like a task
it takes me a little bit longer to do it
and then I will forget the homework
assignment in my room and when you have
ADHD communication is hard so I'm
thinking in the words that are coming
out of my mouth or they're behind where
the words and the point is your words
get jumbled because your mind is going
faster faster than you can speak but
when you have ADHD it's actually not all
bad you see there's some awesome things
about ADHD
when you have ADHD you're really
high-energy here you're up here and that
can be fun right and when you have ADHD
um although you don't focus on
everything when you find something that
you're excited about and you focus you
are hyper focused I joked that I have an
addiction to romance novels and if I'm
reading one of those Tom can poke me Tom
my boyfriend 45 times and I'm not going
to look up I am in the book and when you
have ADHD you're not a linear thinker so
most people go A to B to C and when you
have ADHD we spend time on Z and Q and R
and that's okay because it's actually
kind of fun and creative and you're not
tied to what's rational so now that I've
told you a bit about what it's like to
have ADHD how many of you think you
might know someone that has it very good
glad you raised your hands um the truth
is everyone probably knows someone that
has ADHD 7 percent of the u.s.
population is diagnosed with it and the
crazy thing is that numbers actually
under diagnosed because women and high
achievers find ways to work around it
and we do find ways to work around
things most of the time I joked that my
best protection against credit fraud is
the fact that I lose my wallet at least
two or three times a year I always get
new numbers no chance that I'm gonna get
my identity stolen but um other things
like with the with me being forgetful we
make lists I make so many lists in fact
I have my main points of my talk on my
hand just so I don't forget anything
important and that social thing I told
you about earlier so I was a brat when I
was younger really really a brat and um
got invited to nothing and my dad he's a
child psychiatrist was like hmm what can
I do about this it probably makes sense
that I'm talking about ADHD given the
heath child psychiatrist anyways
instead of giving up on me I remember
there was this birthday party and
birthday parties were a huge deal for me
because as an annoying child they were
the only things I got invited to because
everyone had to be invited to the
birthday party you guys probably
remember that so I was at this birthday
party and I couldn't drive I was in
fifth grade I still so my dad was there
who's watching on the sidelines and I
remember
he told me before I went in he might
pull his ear and if he pulled his ear
that was just a signal that maybe I
wasn't validating someone and I'm
talking I'm chatting with this girl and
all the sudden I see this and it was a
huge turning point for me because I
could suddenly connect um what he meant
he said you're not validating I didn't
know what that meant and then I suddenly
saw and it was the beginning of a new
Maile a Maile that could connect
socially and today it might seem like it
was very I guess micromanaging of my
parents but I am so thankful that they
took the time to give me these signals
because now I have great friends and
they're in the audience today thank you
all so much and I'm so so happy for that
so my point is when you have ADHD you
learn to deal with it
mostly I say mostly because the working
environment is still a new arena and the
inspiration for this talk actually comes
from a pretty personal place when I
started my first job out of undergrad at
a consulting firm I think I was a little
confusing for my manager I bit my nails
I talked too fast I didn't always speak
but when I spoke I interrupted sometimes
and and my presentations were not not
that good and I remember um I think he
just threw up his hands I remember one
day I walked by his office and he said
Maile come in and I walked in and he
said honestly you're working really hard
at presenting and you're getting a
little better but if it's that hard for
you maybe you should just find a job
where you don't have to present and that
was hard but it doesn't have to be that
way and all managers haven't not known
what to do with me in fact when I was at
Caribou my manager Michelle brought out
more of me than I didn't even know it
was there and so what I want to share
with you all today are just four C's
since we all love frameworks so much for
seeds that can help you deal with
someone that has ADHD and really
maximize your relationship with them so
the first C I'm going to tell you about
is coaching you probably picked up on
this but when you have ADHD you can
learn to be different than you are
and so um Michelle really invests she
called on her inner coach and she really
invested in coaching me
and I remember she do things like after
every single meeting where I had to talk
she just give me one minute of feedback
like when you did this with your arm it
was really distracting and that was
really helpful right the other thing she
did to help with me not getting my words
mixed up when I communicated was five
minutes before a meeting that I was
presenting at I just run through the
headlines of my slides and before you
knew it within the first year I suddenly
didn't need her coaching anymore but her
investing in me was very important in
getting me to the place where I could
give big company presentations to get
people energized about our new product
line and I didn't have to worry about
fumbling another coaching thing Michelle
did that was really helpful was at
Caribou it was a cube system and they're
really noisy boys and they pop up over
there cubes and they throw a football
and they yell Miley and every time I did
they did that I would be distracted for
like 20 or 30 minutes really not
productive
Michelle was like Lady go get yourself
to a phone booth go where you won't be
distracted and work there and that was
really helpful she coached me on how to
minimize the chaos in my life and so my
first see for you all is coaching think
about bringing out your inner coach my
second C is clarity if you tell a person
that has ADHD to do something whenever
you get to it or after the next task I
can promise you we are not going to get
it done and then you'll be frustrated
and it just won't be good what works
much better is saying get this done by
Friday and so when you have someone with
ADHD give them clarity about deadlines a
trick that Michelle and I worked on was
I would make a list at the beginning of
each work week of every single task I
was going to do big and small and um I
would send them to Michelle at least for
the first year I think I stopped after
that but she didn't actually micromanage
me with them but the discipline of
putting myself to a list actually help
me execute much better than I had been
before and so your second my second see
for you is clarity think about providing
it find ways to provide clarity now
clarity and coaching those both deal
with leverage minimizing the downsides
of ADHD but this part of my talk the
last two C's are really about how you
can maximize the upsides because there
are some
the third sees creativity and you know
how I told you in the beginning that
when you have ADHD you're not a linear
thinker think about how useful that can
be in a business context put in person
with ADHD in charge of leading a
brainstorm or at least have them at the
brainstorm and those blue sky projects
where you want to come up with a really
innovative solution that's not based on
really anything that's come before it
that's where we're really good and use
us there so the third sees creativity
the fourth sees my favorite and that's
catalyst when you have ADHD you've got a
lot of energy and you've got a lot of
potential and you as a manager should
think about using the person with ADHD
as a catalyst in your organization
there's two main ways I think about this
the first is energy when you have ADHD
you're up and your your bring people
along with you and so you know those
projects the kind of drag work and you
don't want them to end think about
deploying the person with ADHD on that
project and seeing if they can add a
certain spunk that wasn't there before
and then the last is the last thing that
you can use them as a catalyst is you
know I said we can hyper focus if you
put us on a project we like think about
how useful that is Michelle my boss that
I loved put me on snack food I'm
obsessed with eating I do it most of my
life and she said I know what I should
have my own I do snack food I had a
whole strategy written brand a new
product picked out within two weeks and
then the orders placed and then we
rolled at the stores within six weeks
after that and retail that's a fast
turnaround time and the reason that
could happen is because I was still
passionate about what I was working on
so with that and those are the four C's
coaching clarity creativity and catalyst
and you know from my dad pulling his ear
and teaching me how to interact socially
to Michelle helping me navigate the
working world
I think these four C's can actually be
hugely useful for people with ADHD and I
hope that you can share them one day
with someone that has it furthermore as
I got to thinking about it some of the
C's actually seem quite they just seem
like good management and so I offer them
up to you as that as well thank you
you